at 18 years old I'm just did a photo
shoot for Sports
Illustrated I'm one of the best
basketball players in the
country I'm in my first month in college
finally and I said I'll take a chance at
dying if you walk in my house honest to
God you will not see one thing about
basketball my is locked in right now I
do not have one uniform one picture one
article but you'll go to my sink and
there'll be my 15year chip sitting there
on the counter
recovery is the greatest accomplishment
of my
life today we're going to chart a rather
indelicate course through the dark abyss
that is addiction it's an Affliction
that holds the potential to decimate
everything in its path and leave you but
a shell of a human I've been there but
my story just pales in comparison to
that of Chris Haron one of the world's
greatest basketball players a point
guard for both the Denver Nuggets and
his home state Boston Celtics whose
disease took him to just unspeakable
lows before finally getting sober
followed by this extraordinary
phoenix-like journey of recovery towards
purpose towards service and Redemption
as this powerful and leading voice on
the topic of substance use prevention
Chris story which I first came across in
the ESPN 30 for30 documentary called
unguarded is is truly a testament to the
power of
transformation and the unwavering belief
that no matter how far we may fall we
can always always rise again if you are
suffering from some form of addiction
then this episode is a must listen but
even if you're not I encourage you to
embrace this conversation as a means to
better understand an Affliction that
baffles a lot of people especially non-
addicts and and which also likely
touches somebody you know or somebody
you love who needs help now in closing I
want to say that we have additional
resources on the topic of addiction and
Recovery listed in this episode show
notes at Rich roll.com so please refer
to that I think it'll be helpful and
with that being said without further Ado
this is a powerful one with me and Chris
Heron it's great to meet you thank you
for coming out to do this I've been
looking forward to this for years uh I
know you just came from Alabama you were
speaking to the the the college football
team there yeah Alabama football I was
I've been going there for about 12 years
mhm and um I was there Monday then Texas
here and finishing the week at Texas A&M
right so so what is the mix
between uh like college athletes versus
high schools I mean high school high
school kids is really your bread and
butter in terms of yeah yeah I think
you've spoken to like 2 million kids
something like 2 million kids probably
like 200 high schools a year wow and now
middle schools uhhuh you know I first
started telling my story middle schools
wouldn't have me and then a decade later
they know they know that it's it's it's
the appropriate time to uhuh for them to
listen yeah well that's a big kind of
pivot or evolution in how you approach
young people right this idea of not just
sharing your story but also um this
notion of the first day what does it
look like in the early stages of this
because it's very difficult for a young
person for anybody but particularly a
young person to put themselves in the
shoes of the person at the very end of
an addiction story but much more
relatable to get them get their heads
wrapped around what it's like in the
very beginning after about six years of
telling my story I said uh I'm kind of
playing Into The Narrative of you know
finishing my story with how horrible my
life was uhhuh
so I pivoted I did a thing called note
to self for the Today Show and they said
you have to write a note to your younger
self and I've done two books I was like
this is easy 500 Words you'll fly in and
film me and uh it took me about a
month tapping back into that little boy
was
brutal which then told
me try to have the kids identify with
the little
boy not the heroin attic on the street
right um like yourself I was visited it
was I think it was maybe 9th grade maybe
8th grade when some guy came to my
school yeah and got up in front of
everybody and told his you know his his
his
alcoholic uh adventures and I remember
not being able to relate to it at all I
thought it was sort of interesting and
fascinating I still remember when that
happened but it didn't have any impact
on me at all um I know you had a similar
experience and now you're standing in
the shoes of the guy who's going to all
the schools and trying to do that a
little bit differently you know that's
that I felt like I was doing addiction
or disservice right I think we focus so
much on the worst day and we forget the
first day MH we're always painting this
picture of how addiction ends rather
than why it's beginning so when I walked
into schools it was a very uh difficult
decision for me to do I was six seven
years into speaking and I said um I'm
going to Pivot and my whole team was
like you can't pivot so I pivoted
and as soon as I pivoted the Outreach
from kids went up 300 400% wow yeah so
that's when I knew you know that the
first day the first St is what kind of
sticks with the kids right you know cuz
you're meeting them where they're at
self-esteem selfworth trauma
um my childhood yeah you know and
kids kids would see me come in and say
well he was a Boston Celtic but I was
listening to one of your shows and
um the guy said Broken
Toy something about being a broken toy
and it rattled me because I was a I was
a broken toy and that's what I want the
kids to see
mhm yeah I think this is a a a newer
kind of lens or approach to understand
addiction I mean you and I both got
sober and and have maintained our
sobriety within the the traditional
structure of of 12ep and I credit that
program with saving my life and
continuing to save my life I'm still
extremely active in that um so this is
not in any way uh you know a
disparagement on but I think there is a
sort Trope in the rooms around not
overthinking why you became an alcoholic
it's like you are because you are and
and the wisdom in that is that there's
not a lot of
actionable uh uh advice in spending too
much time in your head trying to
understand how you got there we're going
to focus on the tools and the steps to
rebuild your life and create a better
one for yourself and and I get that but
I think now we're seeing with people
like Gabor mate and a lot of you know
social science research coming out the
connection between Early Childhood
trauma Etc that's contributing to these
things and I think it is important to
understand that so that we can catch
people earlier on and address these
issues before they become out of control
listen I'm I am a 12-step guy through
and through yeah you know I truly am if
it wasn't for them if it wasn't for the
12 Steps um I want to be the dad I am
the husband you know it completely
completely changed me it's
just there's other there's other avenues
you know for years we shut those Avenues
down and now there's other avenues mhm
right supplementing what we already know
works right um well let's get into it I
want to do you know an old school like
what it was like what happened and and
what it's like now so you know paint the
picture in in Fall River as a young kid
what was going on my brother was a star
my father was a politician and I was
upand cominging and
uh I grew up in a tough Town blue collar
I mean it was very normal for kids of my
age to be walking into uh the sons of
Italy or the Portuguese American Club
and and having beers um that was the
culture
and the culture caught up with me you
know I went to
BC and uh I was introduced to
cocaine
and not everybody can understand this
but cocaine
became like my
therapy Like Cocaine was my truth serum
what is it about that drug that unlocks
that it allowed me to cry and just spill
everything I needed to spill uhhuh so I
kind of fell in love with the
vulnerability of
cocaine and it ran Wild
right it just it followed me everywhere
I
went um came out to
Fresno couldn't shake it uh went to
treatment came back from
treatment got married in college had a
baby in college that allowed me to step
away from the life for a little while um
but I fell back into it
and you know I was just starting
my career professionally and I was
introduced to oxycon and that was it
that was it yeah so we find the drugs
that work for us and part of the first
day you know kind of idea is
understanding that you know they they
work you know you don't become an addict
because it doesn't work out of the gate
it's it's it's serving it's filling some
need right and as a kid in Fall River
kind of rough and tumble Blue Collar
town you become this Superstar High
Point score 2,000 points in high school
and it's a town in which basketball
looms large it's a Friday Night Lights
sort of scenario right where everyone's
turning up for the basketball games and
you're the hometown hero and as a young
person I mean starting around like age
14 you're suddenly in a position where
you're
shouldering all this pressure and all
the hopes and expectations of this town
I was playing in front of four or 5,000
people in high school that's crazy you
know what I mean so that 14-year-old boy
running through the locker
room came out to 4,000 people and you
have this Comfort you're in your Zone
when you're on the court and you're able
to do what you do so well and yet after
the game when you're in your buddy's
basement you feel like you got to get
loaded just so you can hang out with
your friends like that disconnect yeah I
don't even know if I was comfortable on
the court I might have been you know in
hindsight I think of how I felt I was
kind of in flight you know like I wanted
to I wanted to get it over with you
wanted the games to be over with yeah I
wanted to get to the end I wanted the
result before I had the result I wanted
the points before I had the points
and I wanted to run so I wouldn't even
consider myself ever being comfortable
on a basketball cour wow yeah you said
that that you don't have a lot of love
for basketball was it a situation in
which you at one time you did or was it
always like a Duty
or you know it's like Friday Night
Lights and and and the thousands of
people in the gym
screaming most of my time was spent on
102 Philip Street like my childhood home
and every shot I took every dribble was
was to be
better than my brother better than my
father um it was just this this Shadow
it's hard to explain but it was just
this shadow that I could never ever
escape it so the love of basketball was
gone I never loved it I loved soccer I
loved baseball but I just never love the
game of basketball because it was just
this impending doom
that I was going to
fail but you didn't fail I didn't but I
believe some of that success came
because of fear of failure yeah and like
you can get into it and try to figure it
all out you know what I mean uh and
trust me I've done plenty of work to try
to figure it out
um but when I go back to that little kid
in the driveway like I'm not out there
cuz like I enjoy this I'm not out there
saying this is this is fun I'm out there
for a reason and you know 10 8 10 12
year olds shouldn't be out there for a
reason yeah yeah you should be having
fun um and and of course you're too
young to have any self-awareness around
any of that you're just operating
reactively to this environment and
you're growing up in you know this blue
collar town that that you know miltown
right that's kind of having hard times
that's why basketball was so important
it was this source of Pride for this for
this community um and very much a a a
work hard play harder situation you play
the games then you're in your buddy's
basement and you're partying harder than
you played on the
court I played the games to get to the
basement like that was that that that's
where the piece was for me like let's
get the games over with so I could
finally get down into the basement MH
and um that started at a young age you
know that it was like Refuge down there
like I can escape everything um for
river is a tough town it's tough people
I I believe um it played in to my future
with drugs and alcohol but I also
believe because of it it brought me out
of it yeah and and that toughness
um but as a little boy uh fora wasn't a
safe place for me mentally mhm
emotionally yeah you have the Spectre of
of your older brother and the
expectations that come with that hanging
over you you've got uh an alcoholic dad
a
divorce
um not an awesome healthy
situation for a young person to grow up
in but it feels like you had some
guidance and some
mentors around you but you were
impenetrable I wouldn't say I was
impenetrable right but what I would say
is my parents tried hard you know their
life was falling apart um it wasn't that
they've ever intentionally put me in a
wrong direction right they know exactly
where I should be on the road I should
be traveling on uhhuh but they just
couldn't get me to it um and then Bill
Reynolds walked into my life and you
know he uh he said I want to write a
book about you it's similar to Friday
Night Lights I'm going to call it far of
a dreams and I'm going to follow you for
one season and I'd never been around
someone like that before he went to
Brown he was just unbelievably
therapeutic for me calm
um
and he it it's kind of crazy like he
almost showed me how [__] up I am can
I swear on here yeah all right sorry but
do you know what I'm saying like he
almost showed me like you you you
are you're not an 17y old kid you're not
a 15year old kid
like we need to help you like he started
started trying to help me I never heard
of that word and at 15 16 years old he
wanted to help me and which allowed me
to kind of look
in and that's when things started to get
tough why did that make it tough I would
think this Outsider comes in he's able
to see things a little bit more clearly
than somebody who just grew up in that
town he pulls you aside he saw the truth
yeah but on some level to say to you
listen man you got this huge future
you're unbelievably talented you have
this gift
and I'm watching you piss it away you're
on a crash course With Disaster you need
to figure this
out I didn't know how yeah I didn't like
that's the truth of it right like he
wanted me to figure it out and you know
I Bill Reynolds I was with them a couple
hours a day maximum you know I was I I
wasn't with him like my parents or you
know an adult figure in my life he
popped into for practice
and uh he started just introducing me to
like it sounds crazy but he's the first
person I ever saw eat a
salad I'm not I'm not kidding you I
never saw anybody in my life this Posh
guy from Brown I'm 15 years old and I've
never seen anyone eat a salad uhhuh and
he orders a salad and a Diet Coke and
I'm like who is this [__] guy yeah
you call you say I'm [__] up oh my God
god um are you do you have recollection
or uh a memory of like the first time
you got drunk like you know you hear you
know in the rooms that vividness of of
that first experience and feeling like
oh this is what's missing in my life
like this is the thing that is gonna I
drank Cold Duck champagne in my basement
I think I was in sixth grade sixth or
seventh grade it might have been for my
like
my
13 my my my my birthday party in my
basement yeah um there was a bottle of
warm cold duck and me and my buddies
cracked it and started drinking it and
it just gave me this ability to be
something else like to experience
something else MH you know not be so
rigid and uptight and and worried and
concerned like I could just kind of
loosen up and that was I would say
that's my first experience with alcohol
m mhm but you still
never felt super comfortable even on the
court when you were doing your thing
listen the truth is I don't feel super
comfortable today that's the truth like
I mean there's a lot of work that has
been done and needs to be done and I
just didn't have the vehicle to do the
work back then my mom and dad didn't
have the bandwidth in their world to
help me through it right so I just kind
of white knuckled it and and plowed
through it at that age
um and to a certain extent I kept doing
that for for years yeah well in the
unguarded documentary they make a a
pretty solid point of of looking the
other way as long as you were winning
right like when everything's going great
you're able to get away with a lot more
than you probably would have otherwise
because there was so much success
happening so I think for of to a certain
extent gets a bad rap with that there
was so many people in that area that
wanted nothing but good for me right um
it was an internal issue right that they
tried very hard to to point me in the
right direction
um people looked away in my life yeah I
don't
even I feel sad for the people who
looked away from me because they just
extended this world for me mhm you know
like I wasn't look I guess what I'm
trying to say is I wasn't looking at
people saying like you're a
sucker you're a sucker for looking
away it was an extension for me like I I
I can still go down this road further
you know so high school was pretty much
booze pot some psychedelics whatever was
around uh but things kicked up into
another gear when you get to Boston
College right you say no to Duke you at
Boston College stay local local hero boy
playing in the backyard you uh early in
your freshman year you come back to your
dorm room couple girls in your room some
lines of coke lined up in front of you
and you're faced with a choice I am a
big choice and and growing up as a
Boston Celtic a kid in that area um Len
Bas was was pretty fresh in my head at
that time
um that was was that 19 80 no it was
1987 maybe oh was that much later yeah
yeah I think yeah
um
1986 but
I I saw this pile of cocaine on my desk
and I was like [__] Lenny
bias and
like he just did it once and he died
right it just it kind of shows you how
sad that situation is right like I
literally believe that
there's a very good chance that I'm
going to die if I just do this one time
and I still did it m you know what I
mean like that think of how sad that is
yeah that at 18 years old I'm just did a
photo shoot for Sports
Illustrated a book has been written
about me I'm one of the best basketball
players in the country and I'm in my
first month in college finally out of
for River out of my home
and
I said I'll take a chance at
dying it's kind of wild you know but
that
chance it was and I'm very careful how I
say this but it it
was it was a sort of freedom for me and
people who have done cocaine and certain
people that do cocaine it happens to
them it was my it was my truth serum it
allowed me to just lay back open myself
up and say come on in I'm going to
introduce you to the real me m you know
and that's that's what I that's what I
was addicted to well there is something
therapeutic about that and I think it's
important when we talk
about uh substance use I know you don't
like the word abuse um that addicts find
their way to the substances that
actually fulfill a certain need it's an
unhealthy Avenue but there's something
about that that's working for them that
they discover and as somebody who grew
up in a community where maybe wearing
your emotions on your sleeve you know
it's probably not probably not a lot of
that right um it it it was a it was a
way to feel those emotions and express
them oddly it made me feel
normal you know it just it it it gave me
this sense of Peace it slowed my world
down allowed me to sit on a couch and
just say I'm
afraid like I you have no idea like I'm
in Sports Illustrated but I'm petrified
of what's next and you know you'd wake
up the next morning and say did I really
tell the truth you know did I really sit
down and and and open myself up that way
and again that's that's the thing about
cocaine that I
loved yeah um and then it becomes a way
of life it it works until it doesn't it
was a funny drug right like I I was
never opiates are a different game like
cocaine for me was more like 48 hours
and two weeks off uhhuh you know it was
never an everyday thing yeah it
just it reintroduced them all the time
you know and
and so it allows you to think like I'm
not not I'm not a drug addict because I
haven't done it for a month you know but
it will be 72 hours later and the shades
are drawn and I'm sitting in my house
and I'm you know listening to people
stock their cars go to work get their
book bags for school and I want to die
uhhuh you know very it was a very
depressing drug for me coming down
mhm so you you have this kind of magical
debut at Boston College but it doesn't
last very long you end up failing a
couple drug
tests big news
story um the hometown Hero has been
taken down a peg uh and for somebody
who's harboring so much fear to have
that like RIT large you know in the
newspapers and media figures talking
about you in a less than compassionate
way I can imagine only Amplified that
sense of fear and Doom that was already
inside you you know in
1994 right like there wasn't many
athletes featured as drug addicts right
and that's that was the headline that we
got this problem child this waste of
talent drug addict who threw everything
away 50 mil from his home mhm I think
the most difficult thing for me at that
time was my mom you know my dad
struggled with
alcohol
um I just didn't want to let her down
yeah and she passed away before you got
sober right she didn't yeah she never
saw me sober yeah it was her dying wish
you know
mhm I never gave it to her when you
think back about that 18-year-old kid
mhm what is it that you want to say to
him hug him I'm not going to say
anything I'm hugging him I'm going to
hold him mhm I'm going to hold him real
close real tight and if you had to
diagnose know what was going on with him
the source of his pain and his trauma
that led him to make those decisions and
and walk the path that he did how do you
make sense of that at 18 years old you
couldn't you know no but you looking
back now and understanding yourself with
all the work that you've done on
yourself I'd pull him out of the
game you know I I'd take him away from
basketball yeah um it's dark it's deep
and
uh I had no
tools
nothing so again and it's
probably even 15 years sober it's it's
it's probably wrong to say but I I don't
know what I'd say to
him I would just i' I'd hug him
mhm and I I'd walk through it with him
yeah yeah yeah he didn't have that kid
just didn't have any kind of healthy
mentorship in his life somebody who
could see the kid behind the basketball
Glory you know I'm I'm careful with that
cuz my brother was a steady like as far
as my life in basketball my dad
um the only thing about my dad was his
drinking got in the way uhhuh uh my mom
was phenomenal but at 18 they were going
through a divorce so I got kind of
pushed to the side right so for the next
6 months I sat on my mother's couch
terribly
depressed and Jerry tanian called
me and he said I'm a fan of Second
Chances right I'll never forget that
line I'm a fan of Second Chances MH and
uh I needed that so he seems like he was
an amazing guy and and really believed
in you really cared about you a lot and
invested a lot M he took to his own risk
yeah yeah with you we were both of our
backs were up against the wall a little
bit right he was fresh out of Vegas he
was going home to Fresno I needed to get
out of New England 3,000 miles away I
figured I I I truly believe and you hear
it all the time in the rooms that me
moving from Massachusetts to California
was the solution right the geographic
yeah and you know obviously it chases
you right but in in unguarded you have
you talk about you get you get there and
you're like what am I doing here I don't
belong here you're calling your yeah
yeah I'm at Jack In The Box you're a
jack yeah you're you're like there's the
pay phone you know where I was telling
her I can't I'm not going to make it
here you know well she was the person
that I could be truthful with right she
she knew that boy you know not many
people got to know me in seventh grade
like yeah you met your wife in seventh
grade yeah so she was one of the few
people in my life that I could go to the
Jack in the Box pick up the phone and
say I'm crumbling I'm crumbling in
Fresno California I've never heard of it
it's
120° I need to get out of here um but
the truth is I had nowhere to go right
so it was Fresno a
bust you make a good go of it for a
while there it seems like it was a
relatively healthy environment um with
Jerry's sort of mentorship and belief in
you and a certain you know sort of Team
cohesion there and you had a good run
for a minute I think it started off
Rocky I was I was in a Black Angus
parking lot and surrounded by you know
the SWAT team I got into a fight in the
bar it started off Rocky right you know
um from an athletic standpoint it was
great right like we're playing in front
of 13,000 people selling Arena it's live
Fresno is a lot like Fall River in a
bigger sense it was it was a very blue
collar town and I think they respected
the way I played the game and I think
they respected where I had come from and
you know I I became the the long shot
the underdog um so I think they and I
played that way you know I played you
know when people say Chris you were
talented
um I was
emotional like that's what drove me not
Talent emotion drove me like when I
could kick it into another gear it was
all emotion and fear M so that's where I
believe I I excelled but part of me on
the basketball court and Fresno knew at
some point you're going to try to tap
into this and it's not going to be
there yeah there's that was it the first
game where you come back and you're
you're playing in Boston for Fresno oh
God and and you know Boston fans not
exactly forgiving right booing you you
know here's this kid he's back here and
and you just crush it right so when you
say like like what you're saying is when
the stakes are super high and you could
tap into that emotional state and just
play out of your
mind I look at as honestly humbly I look
at it as lucky like I just I made my
first shot which allowed me to my esteem
to feel comfortable out there I was I
was paralyzed with fear walking into
that Arena I just got my ass kicked to
University of Oregon now mind you I get
kicked out of BC I sit out a year I'm
trying to get my drug problem under
control I'm going to AA I'm working with
my assistant coach
and busted my ass to to to get back and
I step on University of Oregon's
basketball court and they destroy me
they took everything from me that game
and from Eugene Oregon to Boston
Massachusetts I contemplated quitting
like I can't do this I can't I can't
embarrass my family I can't embarrass
myself um I'm not a division one
basketball player I'm so far from that
McDonald's
All-American um just transfer go to a
division 2 school and play at that level
so so for six hours on a plane I cried
like I don't know if I'm going to be
able to do this and I didn't sleep you
know I'm in the hotel and we're
practicing and my family's coming so
there was an immense amount of pressure
on me uhuh
and I didn't do well with that you know
I I I didn't I didn't do I had I had to
create it in a
sense yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
yeah I get it I get it but I'm I'm
imagining just this this young kid who's
just so burdened by expectation and an
outside sense of responsibility like
it's life or death for you like if I
don't play well in this game then this
whole town is going to yeah turn on me
or you know what I mean like and and I
felt that about me you know like it was
life and death for me no wonder you
didn't have joy for basketball yeah how
could you I didn't I think I and that's
my that's what I was saying I think I
excelled
at being
incredibly fearful like that drove the
fire to rip your throat out on a
basketball court right but not that I
could like dribble really good and shoot
un like it it was more of that intensity
that was living within me that allowed
me to thrive out there sure but fuel as
a fuel source fear isn't going to isn't
going to bode well long term and if
you're harboring that much fear all the
time it's only it's you're ticking time
bomb in terms of when you're going to
use against again because you can't walk
around with that level of discomfort
being an adct without picking up at some
point and I knew it was I
knew that this whole gig was going to
end I just didn't know when like you got
to think about it I at 18 years old I
went on this journey to be a a
professional basketball player but at 18
years old I knew at some point I'm going
to self-destruct so every time I walked
into a gym every time I played in a game
I knew at some point it's not going to
be the person across from me who beats
me it's going to be me right and that's
is it going to be tonight it's a
horrible way to live meaning they're
going to find out M they're going to
expose me yeah and and you you know the
amount of like energy that you have to
Output to maintain this double life so
no one no one really knows what's going
on with you is is exhausting so fear
exhaustion um Panic Doom all of
that and like 19 I loved it like I'd be
screaming on ESPN the cameras I'd be I'd
be an absolute Maniac out there after
the game I'd jump up onto the scores
table and get the fans fired up and they
loved it but there was just something
about
that 19 20 year old that as I'm
celebrating I know deep down inside that
this is not going to it's not going to
be long yeah it's not going to last
forever yeah and it didn't you're you're
right about that yeah yeah uh you you
you break Jerry's heart a couple
times uh you know and it kind of you're
you're sort of it's weird it's like this
x like on the one hand your your
career's continuing to go up like you
get drafted you're playing for Denver
then you play for the Celtics um but at
the same time your problems getting
worse and worse and worse right so so
it's this this weird Confluence it is
weird and at honestly I can say at that
time if I look back on it there were
times I was the healthiest I've ever
been you know like at Fresno walking
into a trailer for an AA meeting and you
know opening up the big book and smoking
cigarettes and hugging people like I
felt phenomenal right so there were
periods of time where I had some pretty
strong sobriety at 19 20 21 years old um
and then I went to Denver and you know
it was well document documented that I
went to
rehab and uh you know Rowan Stone did a
big piece and fox did a reality show so
everybody kind of knew um kind of my
Legend and I walked into that locker
room and the guys in there immediately
embraced me and
said you're a second round pick you know
you're 33rd you get two years guaranteed
we're going to make it 10 years and as
men who suffered through substance use
with family members in the past we will
I will not sit back and watch you suffer
so we're going to do everything in our
power for you to take advantage of this
opportunity and they did Antonio mcdice
George McLoud chony bips papey
Jones they knew my history and they were
like it's not going to happen here so
they they babysat for a season and um I
wasn't Perfect by any stretch right but
I was better I was much better and
that's why when I came back the
following year and I got traded yeah it
broke me do you think if you hadn't
gotten traded to the Celtics and you
stayed in Denver that ultimately you
would have been able to figure it out
you know what I found out in the NBA to
be truthful um
my emotion didn't work anymore then it
was real talent then it was real size
you know that fiery tough you know Blue
Collar kid on the basketball court
like that wasn't giving me an edge in
the NBA so whether I self-destructed or
not I don't think in hindsight looking
back I would have had this this long
successful NBA career because I was I
was at my limit uhhuh you know when
you're when your when Shaquille O'Neal
tries to block your shot and you feel
like there's a you know a a tree over
you doesn't matter how angry you are no
yeah that's not going to help but you
got to find some kind of other gear
right that's a little more sustainable
if you're going to operate at the
highest of the elite level and that gear
required discipline it required
sobriety and and I couldn't I didn't
have it yeah you know if I was going to
make this work I'm going to get sober
and I'm going to lock in and I'm going
to show up every day to put the work in
I didn't have that ability so I knew I
knew I was going to lose it um and
that's
why that's why I kind of enjoyed going
to Europe you know I was running away
again you know I I won't fail in front
of I'm going to head to Europe and fail
on my own yeah you're getting paid well
you can do this thing you know how to do
but the stakes are a lot lower and no
one in the US is paying attention and
you can [__] around and you're so far
away from home it's not going to make
the headlines in the Boston Globe I just
I'll never forget it I I I have a
horrible story I don't even know it's
appropriate to be on here right no tell
it
so my wife wanted me to get help
obviously and there was this pain
management clinic in Boston that puts a
pellet inside of you right
so sadly I can't even describe it
because I went up there and it was
$750 and we didn't have
$750 so I walk into this office and my
wife is sitting there and she's so happy
that I'm going to get this block opiate
blocker and planted in me that I
uh I walk in the back to meet with the
doctor and I had a razor blade and go
gauze pads in my pocket uhhuh
so I met with him for about 15 minutes
and I said you know something sir I'm
going to pass on the pellet may I use
your bathroom I walked into the bathroom
I sliced my stomach open I put gauze
pads tape and I walked out and my wife
saw it and she was like way to go babe
yeah and there was no pellet the
$750 addicts are crafty man yeah yeah
but but but saying that is I I took an
immense drug habit you know um intense
drug habit to Italy with me mhm you know
I was and and part of
me if I could like those are people that
I never made an amends to the Italians
the teams that I played for um because
they didn't get what they
scouted you know I got off that plane
and I was taking thousands 1,600
milligrams of oxies a day right that's
the athlete that you just acquired yeah
you know what I mean so so yeah so so uh
opioids oxycotton enter the
picture
um what when was that it was shortly
before you started with the Celtics M
and then that quickly ramps up do A600
milligram a day habit of oxy while
you're playing for the Celtics there's a
crazy story where you're warming up for
a game and you go out shortly before
you're Dope Sick you go out to the
parking lot to score so that you could
just play the game and you end up having
a pretty good game which is like you had
this unreal ability to play high or stay
up all night party your ass off and just
be an absolute wreck and then like four
hours later take the court and and crush
it which is I did so at a younger age
right like when I got that that doesn't
that's not going to it's not it wasn't
going to last for me high school right
but um 1,600 migs of oxycotton a day and
I'm sitting in my locker room and I'm
like I'm not feeling good like the early
withdrawal symptoms are coming on I'm
kind of like I got a runny nose I'm
sneezing and uh starting to get a little
achy and I call my drug deal and I said
listen I'm playing I need you up here
before MH right I'll leave him some
tickets I'll meet you after the game
I'll give you a couple of thousand
dollars and I'll get what I need but I
need you now and he punched it and he
drove and
and I kept running off the floor know
and like think of that moment like I'm
starting and my family they're so proud
of me and and this is the dream growing
up in Massachusetts to play for the
Celtics I guess so right I mean if you
think about it I guess so I mean was it
really apparently you know I don't know
I mean if you really look back at it was
that my dream maybe my dream was to like
paint and like
play music you know yeah I just never
was exposed to anything else but that
but my point is I was
um I ran outside the arena with like
eight minutes to go and the place was
packed and I run I leave the locker room
go left another left down the stairs
through the players parking lot
and he's waiting for
me I pay him he gives them to me I throw
them into my mouth I run back to the
arena and they introduce me shortly
after and that's normal like there's
people who will watch this show you know
and say w that's I get that yeah of
course and there's people who watch it
will say what a sick bastard you
know but yeah and I think a lot of that
has to do with not understanding that
you need that just to be normal without
it there's no way you're going to be
able to play yeah and I I hate not about
like being in some Peak state of being
high of performance yeah you're just
trying to get to a baseline you know I I
think it's always it's it was in the
beginning it was a really hard question
to answer like did you ever play high
and every part of me wanted to say no
but the truth is I wouldn't been able to
play unless I was under the influence
with with the in the world of opiates
mhm you know like I didn't do cocaine
before the game because it was going to
make me perform at a higher level um I
did opiate so I could be normal and
perform at a normal level and that's the
chase right I think you know even as a
professional athlete what what you start
to fall into right I'm I'm strung out on
oxies
and I
am I would try to like get myself away
from it and get in the gym just as
whether it's Sprints runs shots my body
didn't feel right on him I mean w
without him without him yeah so I knew
that I was going to have to step away
from the game of basketball for about 6
months to kind of
rewire my brain and my body to the
muscle memory to to be able to perform
at that level without him wow so I just
chased it was just it was just a
constant
Chase so your time at the Celtics ends
yeah you go overseas you play in all
these countries Poland turkey China
Italy
uh you bring like a big bag of oxy with
you right did you travel internationally
with that TR sh to you or how did how
did you actually
so I brought some to Italy with me I
believe yeah so I brought I I brought it
was probably like 300 oxies with me and
I was like I'm going to manage this and
then the next country I went to was
turkey and I was like there's no way I'm
bringing yeah to Turkey right yeah if
you're of a certain age you saw a
certain movie that terrified you oh my
God yeah so I'm like I'll figure it out
when I get there uhhuh and
uh I went on that flight without I
fought in my hotel room my father came
with me he witnessed my withdrawals um
you know I would wake up and the bed
would be sideways um that's how active
my my legs were kicking and um I
started
really trying to hustle some heroin you
know some some opiates and
uh couldn't find any so for like a month
I'm sick so I call a guy at home and I
said I just wired you 5,000 send me a
bunch of oxies and he sent them and the
plan in a newspaper you can't feel them
FedEx so I get a phone call from my team
that says use a package down at the the
local shop but they for some reason they
want you to come here to pick it up oh
man it's a sting it's total sting wow in
istano I went for it I didn't care about
this thing like there was $5,000 worth
of oxycotton in that package so I go
there and as I'm sitting there at the
counter signing ID
with some of my uh like the team
Personnel outside with me I'm like these
guys are about to witness Midnight
Express like I'm about to get locked up
in turkey and
uh the guy comes around the corner and
he has the package wrapped in tape and
I'm like [__] it's it should I run
should I say it's not mine I grabbed
it so I turn around and as I'm walking
out of there I'm like how come nobody's
tackling me I get in the backseat of the
car I start opening
up when I get to where they were
supposed to be someone in the
airport beat me to
it got rid of all the pills and wrote me
a little note basically like get your
[__] together man this is this is sad
whoa like a customs officer who knew who
you were intered intervened wow mhm that
was Turkey you can't make that [__] up
what you can't make up is the fact that
I went you know like that's that's well
that's I mean that's Addiction in a
nutshell and I think that's what people
who don't have familiarity with this
disease don't understand like it's going
to drive you to just make insane
decisions because nothing else matters
I'm on that drive over right to the
um the FedEx in turkey and I'm like I
have a
child I have a
wife but there's a chance I'm going to
feel
better and there's a chance I'm going to
go to prison and I went for
it that's wild and for many people maybe
that would have been wake up call enough
mhm not for this guy though no no it
wasn't and and sadly right like I say I
I I tell these stories with great pain
and embarrassment you know what I mean
like I
never I don't get any enjoyment or or
it's it's pain painful to say because I
know on the other end of this like my
son who's 25 and my daughter who's 22
they're going to go on and they're going
to watch this interview but they know
these stories and they know you and they
know the way that you've showed up over
the last 14 years but it doesn't mean
they want to always hear them yeah do
you know what I mean like I signed I I
that's when I did
unguarded our world changed that was a
big deal I mean that that documentary is
so powerful and
unbelievable I had no idea honestly and
it didn't even it happened by accident
like John Hawk could tell you most of
the footage the hours they spent with me
was me teaching kids how to play
basketball in a gym at the tail end of
them wrapping up filming I got a couple
of speaking events and he followed me
and he said like this is this is the
documentary right I'm going to tell it
you're going to tell it in your story
um and that's where ardu came from it
was not supposed to be me telling my
story and you know I had no idea 15
years ago 14 years ago how powerful that
would be yeah the mission was to for
outreach right someone just say hey I
want help like if someone can hear my
story and say I want to stop my recovery
process that was really my mission at
its core and I would walk into these
schools and I would tell this story of
my life and they would message me on
Instagram and Twitter and Facebook and
say I'm so happy for you God bless you
hope you stay sober for your
kids I had 3,000 kids in that gym and
nobody told me their
story so I'm like what how am I not
interacting with the like why can't I
get to them um so I pivoted and did the
first day and and you know I don't I
mean it it was said long before I said
it right but I think we put way too much
energy and effort in the the worst day
and we forget the first day you know
everybody wants to say how bad it got
not the reason it began mhm it makes you
look in yeah you know when you think
about it you're a parent right your son
your daughter there's parents out there
that they kid walks in shitfaced
cockeyed you know like drunk first
question is where'd you get it how'd you
get it how much did you
drink who' you do it with what time did
you
finish never
why parents don't ask why right it's
fear and Punishment basically um but the
why is everything I think so I think
that that allows us to kind of open it
right right you know I'm like Dad maybe
my self-esteem isn't as good as you
think it is MHM
why did you feel like you needed to do
that to be with your
friends and the first day idea is this
notion of meeting kids where they're at
by
sharing what it was like for you at the
beginning not necessarily the end
because no high school kid can imagine
that that's how their life is going to
turn out but relating to them why it was
that you made those decisions early on
and then being curious about their lives
and it's also a very compassionate way
of communicating with young people
because you're treating them
like sensient beings as opposed to
judging them or coming at them from this
you know holier than thou you shouldn't
do this if you do this this is going to
happen like it just doesn't work it
didn't work for me right but I became
that yeah that's why I pivoted like I
mean I we started off this interview Len
Bias was the first thing I said and and
that wasn't enough mhm Midnight Express
in a Turkish wasn't enough right EXA
that's not
enough so what what can I do I can try
[Music]
to reverse go backwards get that boy
under the bed on the bed pull him out of
the bed and sit with him mhm and try to
make peace with him yeah you know like I
had a therapist who said to
me
how great would it be to spend time with
that little kid you know like how great
would it feel to like get to know him
you've stored him away for so long like
we need to bring him out and and what
would you what would you say to that
little Chris now I'm a I'm a super
emotional I'm like a big I'm like a big
baby right I would I would cry on his
shoulder man I'd hug
him like people say that to me all the
time what would you say to you young
self I don't I don't know if I'd be able
to
speak I would just hug and hug and hold
and hug I think that's what that would
be my my Approach with with the younger
version of me yeah I've seen you do that
with other high school kids too at the
end of these talks that you give these
presentations you Embrace these young
people and you just hold them and you
say You're Not Alone we're Huggers you
don't even need to say anything more
than that you know yeah they feel heard
they feel seen they feel
understood the recovery Community is a
bunch of Huggers yeah right and
um hugs feel good you know and and to
walk up to to a kid who's struggling and
give them a hug and hold them and and
tell them that I hear them that's why I
do what I
do I want to get through the rest of the
story I want to hear you know kind of uh
how it all how it all falls apart and
and ends up so you're in you're in
Turkey you're in China I hear the heroin
in China's pretty good you're spending
all your money I'm smiling like how sick
am I you said hero in China is good and
I I'm smiling um yes heroin in China was
is extremely good okay um I uh I'll
never forget I I I walked into a
nightclub in China and I was like 45
days sober and I asked this kid if he
could get cocaine like I got a little
buzz on in a nightclub in China and uh
he said ah absolutely and he walks out
comes back in gives me a little bag and
I walk into the bathroom and I do the
line of cocaine and I know within 15
seconds that he just sold me heroin so I
was off and running was that your first
heroin experience no that was in Italy
trolling the train stations yeah the guy
had it tied to his
tooth so like think of that right he
jumps in my car and he starts doing this
and I'm like watching this string come
up and he's got a little baggie oh he
like swallowed
it oh my god wow and and uh and then he
does he shoot you up for the first time
that's how it works and then I went away
from shooting up right then I cuz I was
complet a sniffer and then sniffing
wasn't enough um and then I turned into
like there were people that had to do it
for me and then I went to
the doing it myself where does the whole
house of cards collapse on top of
itself the House of Cards collaps um
multiple
overdoses
um the last time I was
32 and uh I put Chris and Sammy on a
school
bus and daddy is going to walk up to the
liquor store get my pint s
vodka and I'm going to stop at a little
cumbin farms and I steal the
ashtrays
right the cigarettes that were poked out
be were my cigarettes so I would take a
scoop of a bunch of stranger
cigarettes and I would sit at my house
and I would drink vodka and I smoke
cigarettes and wait for my kids and I
got a phone call that
day come down I'm going to take care of
you I jumped in my car drove I had about
a pint and a half of vodka in me no and
I shouldn't he pulled up on the side of
me he threw it through my window I shot
it and I immediately knew that I was
overdosing and the only thing I can
remember is saying the school
bus like I cannot not be there when they
get off the
bus like I cannot have my kids live in
that moment of fear like where's my dad
mhm so I started driving and and they
found me like a mile away crash into a
cemetery and I woke up in the back of an
ambulance
and I thought okay I'm going to the
hospital
um and I'm going to kill
myself like I'll go through the motions
here but once I get away from the police
I'm going to kill myself because I don't
want to do this to my family anymore mhm
I'm 32 Chris is n Samy's 7even Heather's
pregnant like I'm over this and uh and
basketball career is over yeah
basketball's long gone um we had nothing
left food stamps you know no lights some
nights no heat in the house it was hard
like we lived hard and and you're back
in Fall River no I'm living in
Portsmouth Rhode Island at the time my
mom passed away and she left she left me
and my brother
a home and Heather and I were living in
that with the kids yeah but not a lot of
good friends around anymore I didn't
want
support you know a buddy of mine um sent
me a
cage of my mug
shots and like one day they popped up in
my phone like his his like the a collage
of mug
shots and one of my last mug shots
um I was so broken like I didn't
recognize myself right at
all but the first thing I thought of was
Heather she stayed with
him like that
she she she walked with me yeah you know
whether it birthday parties in School
parent meetings I walked with her and
she pulled me along like that like
that's what I thought of as soon as I
saw the mug shot like my poor wife this
woman that you've been with since 7th
grade who stood by you through all of
the insanity and there's two different
ways of looking at that you can look at
that and say what unbelievable fortitude
oh yeah uh and and
belief um that she held in you and your
ability to overcome this and then on the
other hand you can look at it and say
she was insane to stick around yeah yeah
I'm sure everyone in her life was
telling her to run away many times
always
um she wanted that little boy back you
know she saw me probably at my most
innocent uh
phase of my life sixth grade seventh
grade eighth grade you know like I was
just I was still in the driveway uhhuh
you know what I mean I wasn't playing in
front of 4,000 people there were no
lights on me yet um you know she was
someone I could talk on the phone all
night to and fall asleep on the phone
and and talk to my about my parents
divorce right so she's been in it since
the beginning in in the fight you know
it was just a different type of fight
yeah um
but
addiction it causes people to get sick
and and we were both very sick as a
family we were both very very sick
um you
know one year in active
addiction like you close your eyes and
it's 10 years later like you just wake
up I woke up and I was 32 like holy [__]
um time f for all of us yeah but you're
me you're emotionally
stunted so it's like when you finally
stop I'm still emotionally you have the
uh maturity and emotional skills of the
age of the person you were when you
began so you're looking at like a 14year
old right so where we at now like 19
yeah we're probably around I give myself
maybe like
20 I'm hoping I hope in like 26 27 maybe
I'm getting there that's pretty good
yeah yeah I think so the uh prefontal
frontal cortex is it's almost it's
almost online right um so so the mug
shots yeah the overdose the crash into
the
cemetery um is this where you end up in
in in treatment courtesy of Chris Mullen
yeah so it is but but before that and I
I was going I'm walking out of the
hospital and suicide is the plan
like the handcuffs were taken off I was
discharged and I'm walking out and I
said I'm going to kill myself and a
nurse intervened in my life and she
intervened by telling me that she saw me
play basketball when I was a kid and she
was friendly with my mother and my mom
had passed away so her saying she knew
my mom I broke and I'm like I'm thinking
about killing myself but you know my mom
hugged me and she she brought me back
into the
hospital and created the opportunity of
Chris Mullen to come in Chris Mullen
might have never walked into my world if
she didn't walk out of the hospital and
chase me down and she's a nurse like you
don't have to leave the emergency room
and run down the street um that's not in
her job yeah so her name is Diane Reed
um it's because of
her Molly and his wife Liz um gave me
the
gift Molly calls me up and says I got a
buddy named murf and murf is going to
help you go to a treatment
center I've never met murf M right murf
facilitates navigates the treatment
center for me and
um I checked into this Center called
daytop in Rybeck New York and murf
talked a couple times on the phone thank
Tim how you doing checking in y
so
um I go home and relapse murf stops
calling
me um they doubled down on my wife Liz
Mullen murf said you know what we're
going to focus on Heather's well-being
at this point which I wasn't aware of MH
so fast
forward um 9 years sober Maybe 8 years
sober and Molly's getting inducted into
the Hall of Fame and murf is coming I
never met the man that put me in
treatment hadn't met him so I was so
incredibly emotional and ready to hug
this dude and he died that day he never
made it to Springfield Mass wow I never
met them I've never hugged or met the
man that saved my life murf yeah so you
just never know like be somebody's murf
murf didn't need the to be out front you
know yeah but he just did the work for
me he got me there yeah yeah and and
that lingering feeling like you don't
have closure there cuz you couldn't you
couldn't give that guy a hug and and
also knowing your mom your mom didn't
you know didn't survive to see you get
sober oh I've hugged
murf I've hugged them I've hugged them
extremely close and strong for the last
15 years you know like without murf I
wouldn't be here um my mom that was her
dying wish she never saw her son sober I
wish I'm
so I love sitting down with people and
saying like you have an opportunity for
your mom or dad to see you sober and I I
lost that
um but I believe she sees it mhm you
know I believe my mom's kind of walked
with me in this journey I think I
got the murfs and moms behind me yeah um
in that Treatment
Center where you lived for 11 months M
you went out for a minute came back uh
you you you basically find God in this
tiny little kitchen what's it called the
pot wash the
sink uh you know and unguarded there's a
there's a scene where you're standing
there it's this tiny little room with a
bunch of sinks right and you're like
this is where I was from dawn to dusk
every single day it was my punishment
for relapsing right so
so it was behavioral modification they
can't really do it anymore so it's it's
wearing signs saying I'm a scumbag
announcing yourself as a loser so really
um that was that was kind of the bulk of
my punishment for relapsing when Drew
was when Heather gave birth to Drew MH I
went home I relapsed I failed terribly
and I went back completely broken
and they said get in the pot sink so
from 4:30 in the morning till 8 at night
you're going to wash dishes for this
community and there was 96 of us living
in there and
um
lunch breakfast lunch dinner guys would
walk by and just throw trays and dirty
stuff through the window and I had I had
hoses sinks and I would spray him down
and I would get him in the dishwasher
um I had no
contact so I couldn't lie to my wife I
couldn't promise my wife I couldn't over
I couldn't do anything it was just me in
the pot sink and that's when things
started to turn for me a little bit
because you know it's kind of like I let
go and I let her kind of come
in and
uh the next time I talked to Heather she
was pulling up with a two-month-old
infant and my two children walking into
daytop to have a family
meeting yeah this surrender the letting
go uh the the the finally putting to bed
any idea that you're there to save your
marriage or to be whatever like letting
go of all of that and just focusing on
being present with what you're doing
just be still right allowing whatever is
meant to happen happen I know that uh
one of the counselors said something to
you like you know the most compassionate
benevolent thing that you could do is to
call your wife and and tell her you're
never coming home and it went it went
even up a little deeper um he said play
dead for them like why don't we fake
your death car accident and
and let them go let your children
emotionally you know get rid of you in a
sense and um I said that to myself
countless nights like I knew that there
was a better man out there than
me I knew my wife deserved a better man
than me MH I knew my children should
have had a better dad than me provider
and um but when he said it it kind of
hit
me you know like I went to bed with that
now narrative
um but him saying that out loud to me
was probably extremely Reckless
therapeutically MH but it's one that I'm
extremely grateful for yeah I mean I
feel
like among the you know countless
relapses and many stabs that you had
that you had made into sobriety nothing
was really able to penetrate your core
until your wife said that's it I'm done
and this guy said pretend your family
dead right and that that seemed to seep
into you in a in a in a way that really
changed you yeah really profound moments
right like
Heather the
nurse right all of a sudden the Mullins
with
murf and you know the counselor the
Angels the eskimos yeah yeah the
sharpers yeah to get me up everybody
needs one to get me up that mountain
absolutely and anybody can be that
person for somebody else and I'm really
proud of that like I
I I am so incredibly blessed
that in my recovery I've I give it to
others in a sense you know like it's I'm
here because of them MH and I've always
lived that way from the f I went to bed
at night dreaming of being Chris Mullin
that was my dream not Chris Mullen the
the shooter Chris Mullen that man who
picked up the phone and helped me and my
family I dreamt of that like that was my
the game of basketball and millions of
dollars was no longer my dream my dream
was just to be on the other end of that
phone call
and I think I've made that dream come
true you 100% have um it's it's one of
the principles our primary purpose is to
stay sober and help another alcoholic
achieve sobriety but you have taken that
to an entirely new level my friend
because you are not only of unbelievable
service to so many people you've
repaired your life you've you know
repaired all of your relationships with
your family Etc you're this incredible
incredibly present dad and your entire
life is about giving back this gift that
you've been given and that's rare I mean
service is part of what it means to be
sober in this program but um but to
really shoulder that responsibility and
take it so seriously that you're you
know delivering I don't know 200
speeches a year like you're constantly
on the road you have a self-awareness
that your story resonates because of you
know the extraordinary things that
you've done with your life and that
gives you a rare opportunity to connect
with all kinds of people because they're
going to pay attention to you in a way
that they might not to somebody else and
for some of those young kids it's their
first introduction to what a sober man
looks like you know and what their
stories sound like um Heron project you
know my Foundation that was the dream um
Heron talks evolved into me traveling
and telling my story and uh and now you
have a treatment you have two treatment
centers right and I love it mhm I
like I keep it real Raw
that I'm not a clinician I'm not I'm the
furthest thing from that I don't pretend
to be because I'm have a foundation
around substance use I have a a Wellness
Center I'm just I'm just how they say
like a bozo on the bus you know and but
I get a front row seat I watch families
husbands like me fathers like me walk in
on day one and then to sit in their Year
celebration and see their children like
that's not many people get that
opportunity yeah you know not many
people that's that's what's so
incredibly beautiful about alcoholic
synonymous is you know the guy used in
old time he used to tell me wait till
you see the miracle mhm and I honest to
God in the beginning I thought he was
talking about me I'm like okay one day
I'm going to look in the mirror I'm
going to see the miracle so you believed
in that from the get-go no not what I
believed in is that I was the Miracle
wrong it was the newcomer that walked in
at like 18 months and I
witnessed I witnessed their CH see the
lights go on in somebody else right that
was the miracle yeah yeah yeah you just
got a big smile on your face yeah like
your whole facial expression just
changed and that's how I know it's for
real you know
um in all of the talks that you've given
all of the kids that you spent time with
like what have the kids taught you about
how to communicate with young people and
how to understand them I mean there's a
lot of parents I suspect listening to
this who maybe have a kid who's having a
hard time maybe it's substances maybe
it's not maybe it's something else but
like just being a teenager no matter who
you are and where you live is [__]
hard and I think a lot of parents myself
included it's like how do I understand
this young person how do I connect with
them how do I get on their level and
you're almost like a
like you're uh what do they call it like
a not a souser like you're you're like a
Whisperer like a teen whisperer on some
level I'm me just to me I look at it as
I'm I'm a vehicle right like there's
plenty of people that are going to
follow up on my message that can deliver
what they need right and that's why with
Heron
project years ago we hired clinicians
because I felt irresponsible walking
into a school telling my story because
there was nothing there on the back end
so now we have the back end right so
when I walk into a school and I tell my
story those kids reach out those kids
will be helped you know we we will find
we will we deliver for those kids um so
I'm I'm just a small I'm just a small
part of it you know like and I like that
I like the fact that you know I'm in
that school for an hour and a half and
I'm going I'm I'm going to tell my story
and I'm gonna hopefully get whether it's
good or bad get kids to walk out and and
tell a little bit of theirs did you ever
imagine that your life could have so
much impact like it's crazy it's so far
beyond anything that you could have ever
achieved even if your wildest dreams as
a basketball player that come true like
what you're doing now is so much more
meaningful and and profound it is and
and I but I in full transparency I got
to be careful with it mhm you know like
I've run run hard for the last 14 years
I've run really hard and getting up and
sharing your story and talking to all
these kids is not recovering you can
delude yourself into thinking well all I
do is recovery all day long not even
close actually it pulls you away from it
it's working at Cross purposes and I'm
very I'm very open and honest and I tell
people in my Center that are current
currently living there year 12 to 15
were the toughest years of my
life
why
because I I I drifted
away I drifted away from the core I
isolate I put I isolated myself you know
covid all of it it just pulled me away
from where I needed to be and it was an
extremely difficult three years and when
I celebrated 15 years the other day um
congrats man yeah no doubt I uh that's
right August one right yeah yeah I Shar
that you know that it was 15 was a a
[__] like to get there you know
it wasn't it wasn't easy
um
and I had hip replacement surgery on
June 8th uh July 8th and
um after hip replacement I lost Bill
Reynolds and I lost the man by like he's
on my arm
I got it way before he passed away I
lost Chucky
Monas I lost the two men in my life that
were willing to tie themselves to me
during the
storm like the two men who would they
would anchor to me in a heartbeat no
matter how high how low they were with
me and uh I came out of surgery and I I
was told that I lost them both two days
apart oh wow and I'm laying in bed and
I'm recovering from from hip
replacement but I guess you got access
to drugs if you want it I guess yeah but
I guess the point is is for me where
what recovery allowed me to see
is God kept me
still
like hip surgery
like I was in I was in his hands mhm I
was still I couldn't run I couldn't do
anything but face what I was facing and
uh you know it's it's a perspective that
recovery has that allowed you to to kind
of
reinvest in what you know Works totally
and get back yeah yeah I mean I went
through that Co was rough man I really
struggled with the zoom thing and it's
only recently that I've really tapped
back into like my
core guys Co was like the exact opposite
of what I need yeah you know what I mean
like let me drag you out way into the
woods and try to find your way out of
here and my disease is telling me like
oh isolation I can do this I like this
yeah right why I I was living saying how
come they didn't have covid when I was
shooting heroin you know what I mean
like I would kill for covid back then oh
my God yeah yeah man I think it was not
great for the recovery Community um I'm
not you listen 12 to 15 was a beast 1
through 12 I walked right through it 12
to 15 was was a battle Yeah you know how
do you think about the languaging we you
know I'd mentioned earlier like you you
you shy away from saying substance abuse
you like to call it substance use um and
you're very conscious about word choice
when it comes to how you talk about this
condition I am I think it's necess area
I think it's it's kind of softened the
stigma that's that that is attached to
it I um I don't like the word Rock
Bottom
um why refer to probably your saddest
moment in life as Rock Bottom um I just
think we have to be better I think we be
well I think the I think behind that at
least for me is uh is the fact that we
already hate it we already hate
ourselves we're already like our own so
let's so when yeah on top of that you
know a headline in the globe that says
what a shame or whatever it's like we're
already ashamed of ourselves ter so
you're just you're just basically
putting kerosene on that fire and and
amplifying the guilt and the shame and
the fear and all of that and a
compassionate approach to treatment and
Recovery requires or or could use a
little bit more of of empathetic
languaging around it I think so you know
you know I try very hard at it I think
it's it's necessary I think you
know again I don't think they could have
the headline what a shame today right I
think if I found myself in a Dunkin
Donuts Drive-thru overdosed with a
needle I don't think the newspaper would
say what a shame and I think that shows
you how far we've come in the last
decade two decades around substance use
and addiction you're out talking to
professional coaches and athletes what
is the state of the union in terms of of
kind of recovery awareness in the
professional leagues or on the college
teams so that there's some kind of
safety net or something in place for the
kid like you who shows up and has a
problem the safety net is that they're
bringing me in yeah but but that's not
enough yeah there needs to you know what
I mean like there's not there's not a
there's not a lot of
of alternative support in a sense when
it comes to that type of stuff like I go
to
schools very wealthy successful division
one football programs and I'll sit down
with a coach who's been there for seven
eight years and he's never sent a kid to
treatment how is that possible how is
that possible he's got 12 18 to 22 year
old kids and you never sent one kid to
treatment and then there's other coaches
and without even getting into it because
I don't I would I would I'd want
permission
um he's one of the best coaches to ever
Coach and he's all about it he's all
about sending kids away mhm he's one of
the best coaches that will ever step on
a football field
and to me that's his greatest
achievement that when his players are
struggling he sends them yeah yeah if
you were in charge if you were running
the nc2a or you were the commissioner of
the NFL or whatever what kind of
programs would you try to create would
just be a lot of awareness right a lot
of like I I don't I don't even think
there's kids out there that understand
what recovery is you know I think we
show up to a college campus and it's
like here's the weight room MH here's
the locker room here's the gym but what
about there's the frat house and there's
the bar what about my mental health you
know how about when things get really
low for me where do I go then
who do who's going to kind of catch me
when when I'm when I'm struggling we
don't do enough of that you know I think
I think we're getting better but I think
athletes have been looked at as race
horses we got four years of this kid in
college and we'll see what happens right
and to even discuss or bring up the
topic of of mental health is to is to
kind of imply weakness and you're not
here to be weak you're here to be strong
so you're struggling keep it to yourself
and you know buck up but most people
show up with mental health yeah of
course like who doesn't of course you
know what I mean of what kid isn't going
to show up to a college campus and have
some type of trauma something that he's
going to need help with MH
um but we have to wait to Rock Bottom
yeah or or something happens the cops
get involved yeah that's when we react
right
so um what's the advice that you give to
the parent who comes to you and says my
kid's got something going on I don't
know how to communicate with him or her
um I don't know how to get this kid to
pay attention and understand that he's
headed in the wrong direction I'm sure
you get that question a lot let a
professional step
in let it let somebody step like for
instance my dad like I hate saying this
but he's drinking himself to death
currently my dad's dying from alcoholism
and he lives 10 minutes from me and it's
crazy because obviously he knows what
you're doing and what you've done of
course and that just speaks to the
insanity of the whole
thing I've never listen I've sent away
through Herm project and I say this very
humbly like thousands I think 4,000
people in the last 10 years to treatment
through Heron project through my
Foundation
um I can't help my
dad it's too close it's too raw it's too
intense like I have to let others uhuh
intervene and have a conversation with
him um I can't do it as much as as as as
with everything I've been through the
experience I have the the wellness
center the foundation
I'm still a boy talking to my dad yeah
and it's really hard for parents also
because you don't want to be codependent
you want to keep the channel of
communication open but you don't want to
be a doormat either yeah uh and and it's
very confusing and I think a lot of
parents they're afraid to share their
vulnerability you know I think there's a
lot of parents out there like I get
listen I kids email me all the time
after I go to the school and I think
there's a lot of parents out there today
acting like high school was the best
time of their life and their daughter is
completely lost and clueless because
she's not living up to that expectation
like high school is really really hard
and it has been hard and I think parents
don't want to share those vulnerable
moments you know and just an example
like so Jordan Shaq Kobe I played
against
them there's a guy named Richie melon
who bullied me in sixth
grade I can I can tell you everything
about Richie melon what he want to
school some days where he waited for me
I can't tell you anything about Michael
Jordan but I can tell you about Richie
melan uhhuh that says a
lot and I think there's there's there's
a lot of parents out there that don't
want to share those moments M those
losses with their
children which it could be an
opportunity to identify yeah you know
yeah yeah I think that kind of
vulnerability is always rewarded and
appreciated me too um there's so much
talk about the op the opioid crisis and
now increasing awareness around Fentanyl
and what's going on there it's insane um
but I don't think there's
enough solid conversation around what's
going on with marijuana and marijuana
psychosis it's almost as if Mar Marana
has become so
mainstream that there's this idea that
it's benign at worse and as somebody
who's on the front lines with all of
these kids like what cuz I know what I'm
hearing and seeing like what are you
hearing on the scariest it's the
scariest thing I see in my Center as a
father right like I have a 22y old a 15y
old and a 25y old um when a kid who
shows up at my center with Mom and Dad
holding their suitcases and he's in a
psychosis it is it it it rocks me to my
core it hits me in places that I don't
normally get hit and uh I've never seen
it um I've been in psychosis crystal
meth and and cocaine but the marijuana
psychosis that I've witnessed um with
kids and young adults is is one of the
scariest things you know marijuana and
alcohol have gotten a hall p pass mhm
you know like fentanyl has become
the the
headlines and the truth is 70% of this
country currently of people in treatment
are in treatment for
alcohol but nobody says it yeah you know
and now marijuana like you said benign
they they framed it they structured it
they marketed it they sold it as benign
right I mean in Los Angeles there's
billboards dispensaries everywhere and
the dispensaries look like Apple Stores
so the messaging and the marketing
particularly to young people is this is
aspirational right this is nothing to be
scared of or to have any kind of
trepidation about and I can just tell
you as somebody living here who's
apparent to young people it's so
unbelievably accessible alcohol is is
far secondary to to marijuana yeah with
young people it it has now taken over
right it's it's like you said it is
alcohol is secondary
um it's I never thought
that I would see the impact I've seen
around marijuana I was uneducated on it
right I almost thought it was benign
right it gave me the munchies and made
me eat you know like little paranoya
when I was a kid today's marijuana is
different than yeah it's it's so potent
potent and
um it just breaks my heart from a again
and I'm very careful with this right
although I've dedicated my life around
parts of recovery I'm also in the
room right and I'm one of MH so I tend
to stay away from that little expert
seat and stay in the middle of the pack
and um it hits me on a on a level that
um that I haven't been hit on in in the
long time when I see kids coming into my
center with marijuana psychosis so what
does that look
like a little
schizophrenia um
outbursts complete isolation and going
inward um it comes out in different
forms right um but the SK scary thing is
you don't know when it's going to clear
mhm you know like a doctor can't walk up
to and say your daughter's psychosis
will be done in 12 days you just don't
know you know we've had young adults
come into our Center that stayed 6 to n
months and still struggle M and then
we've had we've had young adults that
came in and after a month you saw
Improvement just it's just you can't
call it yeah what is it uh that you're
doing in your in your centers in your
treatment facilities your wellness
centers um that maybe is a little bit
different than what one might find at a
typical Treatment
Center when I opened it six years ago I
said I'm going to offer as much as I can
right so I didn't go to a center like
mine um there was kind of the narrative
like you got to go to a place that it's
hard in order to get it you know and I
didn't want to live there um
so very holistic nutrition sleep
yoga guided meditation breath work um
personal trainer you get all of that at
my right like all like yeah yeah yeah so
it's not just cig cigarettes you know
sitting around a circle yeah no no no no
no I couldn't live with myself you know
what I mean like I couldn't be that guy
you can make a lot more more money being
that guy in the business yeah like if I
just threw a bunch of big books and and
throw out cigarettes and and said come
back come back here in an hour it'd be a
lot different
um but people find peace in so many
other places and again
like why don't people track sleep in
early recovery right like let's kind of
gauge when you're going to be at your
best the next day you know like maybe
you only slept 4 hours maybe that's not
the best time to go sit down with your
life coach your therapist why don't you
take a couple of hours get some rest and
we'll revisit this later mhm you know
what I mean like we can be much more um
dialed in yeah you know I think there's
so much room for impr improvement oh in
this space I mean I was lucky enough to
go to a great treatment center and I was
there for a 100 days and saved my life
and I just you know I can't say enough
good things about it but I know there's
a lot of [__] in this industry you
know it's heartwarming to you know sit
across from somebody who's doing it
right and is thinking about how to
really serve because there's a lot of I
don't I don't I don't even want to call
them treatment centers like uh you know
so we're living houses Etc they're like
hedge fund guys real estate plays
renting Mansions what it is and they can
they can rent out those bedrooms for a
multiple on whatever their you know
whatever the mortgage is and they're
just churning cash and has nothing to do
with helping people get better and
that's someone else's story right like
for me I get I go so far into it that I
track the obviously the length of stay
male or female average age I track I
have data on which life coach in my
Center is best with young adults women
men you know under under 30 over 30 so
if someone comes into my center and and
she's 45 years years old and she's a mom
I'm putting in her I'm putting her in a
specific room with a woman who's like
42% with women her age right you know
like I'm I'm identifying that before you
know you you you you have a a small
window of time with this you know it's
like 30 days 60 days 90 you don't have a
lot you don't have a lot of time they're
going through detox they're going
through withdraw they're they're not
sleeping at night they're struggling
with their nutrition they don't have
enough energy um
so I wanted to kind of come in from
every angle I possibly could at my
center and at the end of the day it's
I'm very proud of it um but it's also
the community MH that you create mhm
right like that's what kind of
keeps keeps you sober yeah of course of
course do you have any read on what
distinguishes the person who makes it
from the person who can't because this
is the the baffling question of all time
right like I've been in rooms with
people thinking that that guy's never
going to make it and that that person
becomes like just a a pillar of sobriety
and you know vice versa I'll tell you
this time
matters like success in long-term
sobriety the the length of stay within
your Center is a complete um it can't be
denied you the amount of people who
celebrated one year two year three year
four year 5 years at my Center that
stayed 30 days or less is minimal right
the ones who stayed 90 days or more I
mean we have a whole Squad of them yeah
I can remember I I've never understood
the 28 day 30-day thing I I I just don't
think that you can you can really make a
change in that I when I was in treatment
at 30 days I was barely awake who's the
[__] that came up with it I don't
know I don't know where that came from
5-day detox 28-day program 9 day
outpatient program like who came up with
this you know like there's people who
were detoxing for a month and a half and
you only giving them five days on your
health insurance like there's people
that come to my center and 40 days into
it they're still struggling you know but
they're not considered medically in
detox at that time um and the truth is
at my Center we meet the real person on
like day
25 like seriously like no [__] I got
four days I'm like days I know three
weeks of you but we got to throw that
out now I know who you really are let's
start over you know and introduce
yourself um that's when people start
trusting you know three three weeks
three and a half weeks in they start
feeling a little better about themselves
and
they they trust and they're going to
start being open and transparent and
vulnerable and that's where you that's
where the work begins right that's where
it begins yes but 28 days they're out 4
days later right meanwhile uh you know
we need a lot of reformation in terms of
how Insurance works with this access to
you know legitimate uh treatment in
patient care all of these things need to
be modernized and and updated to what's
actually happening I mean I'm proud of
it yeah like I'm should I'm super proud
of it and I'm a a man in recovery and
who spent a lot of his life in the last
15 years of my life around recovery and
um it's it's my greatest accomplishment
you know Heron Wellness Heron project
Heron talks it's uh I'm I'm I'm
extremely proud the way we we have all
carried ourselves meaning the runners in
Heron project the students who I spoke
in front of and um the people who
trusted me at her and wellness like
that's [__] big time like when a mom
and dad like I see a mom and dad coming
in from you know Colorado and I'm like
they're opening up their trunk and
they're grabbing suitcases and they're
coming to me yeah like you just flew 4
hours to drop your daughter off at my
place yeah you're the guy in the pay
phone in front of Jack and the bo
[__] big time man that's big time you
know and that's I I never lost sight of
that I never lost sight of the what a
what a complete
honor um that I've been given by
servicing right but I see somebody who
who relishes and Embraces that
responsibility which is a huge
responsibility in comparison to the
responsibility when you were young which
was egod driven of like acquitting
yourself on a basketball court because
you lived in a town that you know wanted
you to do that I mean these are totally
different things that one I mean
obviously you were young and you didn't
have tools Etc but that all that did was
create fear and now you have this
responsibility that's much greater and
Graver literally people are putting
their Liv lives in your hands wild and
you're like fired up yeah [__] right
yeah well like like I I can't paint the
picture or or tell it any better like
there's a mom and a dad in the parking
lot pulling out a suitcase to come live
at my place like what a [__] honor
man like what a responsibility what a
duty you know and I'm I'm extremely
proud of that like we've created
something really special there and you
know we hope people stay longterm become
part of the community and uh and we do
everything I do everything in my power
to to service them while they're there
yeah you know how does this work as a
parent you have three kids and none of
them drink or use right no and never
have no which is wild yeah yeah how did
you accomplish that I don't know I
think it's their accomplishment you know
that's their it's their story um
you know interesting is
that although they've never drank or
used I see some of my behavior in them
mhm right and my but that should make
you even more impressed yeah no son you
know what I mean yeah but there's parts
of them especially Christopher and
Samantha they were nine and seven they
saw N9 and seven years of a horrible
side of me you know reactionary and
aggressive and constantly in Flight
pushing everybody away um and that comes
out in them once in a while and I was in
the
kitchen like a year ago and my little
guy um reacted to something and I was
like [__] there it is that's
me and he sat down and I walked up to
him and I
um I put my forehead on his forehead and
I said sorry
and then I realized that's the first
time I've said sorry to Christopher that
way I'm coming up on 15 years sober at
the time and um I haven't made an amends
like
that we cried like for 30 minutes my
wife who is a crier like she just sat
back in the kitchen and watched us and
was like you know what the hell is going
on right now we all
that motion guttural like came out of us
um but I said sorry and it
was I think what he needed and what I
needed yeah you know which is pretty
[__] cool yeah so honesty open
communication
vulnerability owning up your your
mistakes as a parent yeah yeah I mean
it's superpowers really yeah right
um
they've been able to
witness for thems what recovery's done
for my life for their life for our
family um they've had a front row seat
and it scares me because they have not
done drugs or gotten drunk
um cuz I feel
like I hope I didn't scare him away from
you know like and I say that like I hope
it was attraction not promotion right I
hope they say wow dad sober like that's
that's dope that's [__] cool but in
honesty it's probably a little of both
totally there there's nothing wrong with
that yeah yeah no doubt take if at some
point down the line they dabble with it
or whatever the longer they wait the
better they you know the better chance
they are of being uh you know like not
having that kind of like addictive
response because their brains are more
developed back to the brain yeah 25 26
years old yeah yeah well you're kind of
back to the X like you're you're at the
same emotional age right now so you guys
should just be like a house on fire yeah
no
[__] right H oh man
um there's something
so you know you would you you had said
earlier like I I don't like you know you
still struggle with some regret and some
guilt around your behavior and and and
you know the the the graveness with
which you take sobriety but there is
something about levity in the rooms that
I think is beautiful and it's just
incredible to sit and witness somebody
get up and tell their story and just own
every aspect of it every embarrassing
you know sort of Shame inducing you know
corner of what they experienced and
doing it in service to other people so
that we feel less alone and I think that
takes a lot of courage and a lot of
vulnerability and when I started this
podcast I mean I've been so impacted by
that that I wanted to bring that
sensibility to this for everyday people
because I believe storytelling is such a
a powerful connector and I think we
learn through stories like you can say
don't do this do this and here are the
reason or whatever but when you're on
the receiving end of an incredible story
well told that will take up residence in
you and and linger and remain with you
and influence you in ways that you know
you may not even imagine and I think
you're very gifted at that um and I know
that you know kind of in in more recent
years you're like I'm I'm getting sick
of telling my story or whatever bored of
myself or whatever but I I think that
you you have to remember like there's a
lot of people out there who haven't
heard it yet totally you know and it is
so powerful yeah and I walked in here
today and I said you know
like I said how incredibly blessed is he
to have the people come in and just open
up to you you know like like you said
take up residency like it's it's amazing
um the people that you've met just doing
this and the people that I've connected
with in the past 15 years
um my
story will always be hard
like if I'm comfortable telling it get
me the [__] out of the
room like if I'm that guy then like
people ask me am I nervous I'm nervous
24/7 to be honest with you I'm on the
edge of my seat right now I'll I'm
speaking tomorrow and I'll be pacing
before I walk out in front of a small
crowd right if I'm not nervous like get
me take care of me because I'm not as
healthy as I as as I'm presenting to be
yeah yeah yeah that's interesting I
would have thought you would have had
more peace with it because you share it
so much you know yeah it's still
haunting you quite a bit it is in a good
way though right like I I think and and
and
again 15 years like H it's The Echoes
right like I'm telling it and I'm
worried about my children you know and
the impact it has on them yeah it was
very like it was very hard in the
beginning like I would walk into a high
and speak and my son was in high school
I mean the amount of little hate little
messages he gotten on Instagram because
his daddy the drug addict was at this
school like it was painful you know we
had some major moments as a family like
is it worth it for us you know hurt
people hurt people right you know and
they they went out my children wow for
my story I didn't know that yeah so he
that there's been a there's there's been
a lot of sacrifice on both ends yeah I
would imagine it's a little a little
different now because when you started
speaking you only had a couple years of
sobriety at that point right like you
you you hit that hard early most of my
presentations are the first day that's
what pretty primarily right there
probably 220 a year and the majority is
for first
day I probably tell my story 20 times a
year where it used to be the opposite
yeah you know but again at a certain
point I started feeling too scripted
like you got to start checking yourself
yeah that's that's not good no yeah like
am I too [__] am I too scripted and
then you're like did it happen that way
just [__] it's weird I know i' I've
had that experience yeah it's not it's
not a great feeling and that makes you
not want to share your story or or to
really deconstruct the whole thing
because you're like I've said it so many
times is that what happened or is it
because I keep saying that that I've
convinced myself that that's the way
that thing happen
and you say it so many times it's tough
to connect to yeah like you keep going
to it and you got to latch on to it
right so then you get into
self-preservation and it's like stay
away from that because you're exhausted
mhm you know like now you you've you've
gone across the boundary of you you're
exhausting yourself you're hurting
yourself therapeutically by saying this
stuff so much yeah so you try to kind of
get some separation in it and then it's
I mean it's it's yeah it's tough to
manage yeah yeah yeah no I feel I mean I
can't imagine doing that much public
speaking you
know I can only do it a couple times a
year yeah that's it um well we should
round this out but I I I want to end it
um yeah with uh with a word about a word
towards the person who's out there who's
still suffering um maybe somebody's
listening to this they're confronting
their own behavior for the first time
maybe maybe they're snapping out of
their denial maybe they're wondering
whether they have a problem or not and
maybe need to look at it what is what is
the message you want to leave people
with before we end this
thing again you just you gave me a
snapshot of about 15 different I know
sorry I 15 different people I was like
I'm gonna ask this one question and then
I complicate no no I I I think this the
freedom you know the freedom to look
within the the the the freedom
to take a chance on yourself to to find
a different version of you
um
again recovery is the greatest
accomplishment in my life it has nothing
to do with the Boston Celtics if you
walk in my house honest to
God you will not you'll walk through my
home and you will not see one thing
about
basketball I do not have one uniform one
pitcher one ring
one article in my home so anybody who
walks into my home doesn't say like oh
there's a basketball player who used to
live
here but you'll go to my sink and
there'll be my 15-year chip sitting
there on the on the on the counter you
know you'll go to the coffee stand and
you'll see you know something with
recovery you'll know that before you'll
know basketball and I'm just proud of it
right I'm I'm I'm super proud of it and
never in a million years did I think on
June 4th 2008 when I was walking out of
that hospital life is going to get good
life is going to get real good and life
got good there's always hope totally
yeah you did the work man you
know I love it um thank you you're a
gift dude uh it's super inspiring to
talk to you I love um hearing your story
but also really appreciate
the humility that you bring to the whole
experience you know and and and at times
discomfort with sharing some of that
stuff you know I could sense that but I
think it's really powerful and uh you're
a Beacon of Hope for so many people and
there's a lot of people suffering out
there right now you know so we need more
guys like you I'm blessed to be a beacon
right you are so you are and you wear it
well you look good man thank you brother
yeah um At Your Service if there's
anything I can do to help you and uh
yeah man I'd love to stay in touch love
you awesome cheers thank you
peace that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change and
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. roll.com if
you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcasts on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review and or comment supporting
the sponsors who support the show is
also important and appreciated and
sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason Cameo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davey Greenberg graph traffic and social
media assets courtesy of Daniel CIS
thank you Georgia W for copywriting and
website management and of course our
theme music was created by Tyler Patt
traper Patt and Harry matthys appreciate
the love love the support see you back
here soon peace plance
[Music]
namaste
he